well he's a completely different person
I mean even in the original kills you
started out as sort of a naive callow
you
and there was progression during Empire
where he became more and more trained as
a Jedi and eventually became a full Jedi
and the third one so he had an arc and I
think Harrison Lee Gary fully admitted
that their characters were pretty much
the same throughout so Luke is always
changing now we have this 30 year gap
between the film's so a lot of it is
conjecture and I mean we can't really
it's not specifically my story ray now
is the protagonist so I think you'll
find some things that might surprise you
and they certainly surprised me I said
you Ryan I said I think I fundamentally
disagree with pretty much everything
you've decided for me now having said
that I have to accept it get my mind
around it and do my best to realize your
vision and once I got into it a lot of
my fears were went away but you know I
like doing voiceover it's anonymous you
get to be a character actor and I don't
need the applause or the same this is
just like a real to high profile for my
liking
seriously so I just want to make sure I
don't mess it up that's why I enjoy like
rogue one so much so you guys I'm not in
so you're bowing out after this one you
think you are good to be determined what
how Luke's relationship with Ray
different from Luke's relationship which
they hope you want to yodel well did you
hear the last line of the teaser it was
Li well that said I needed yeah well
there we go
I mean that Yoda and obi-wan didn't kill
that did what do you thinking akela yeah
we sent up to wait for ready are you
bombing bad who's getting gets whatever
reunion with Han Solo absolutely in fact
when I was reading it I thought if lei
is trying to mentally contact me and
she's not successful
she'll rush to his aid she'll get close
to him and then get into some dire
situation and that's when I show up yeah
save her life and we rushed on and are
in the same position that grey and thin
and Chewie are too late to save him but
witnesses and I said because they're
carry so much emotional resonance into
the next film random for other his wife
his best friend to witness instead of
two characters have known in what 20
minutes ago well Julie but still no I
thought there was a great missed
opportunity but listen I as I told JJ
and I told Ryan I have so many really
terrible ideas I'd love to share with
you because out of hundred you'll find
one of your kinds of life afternoon
comes out I'm making a list of some of
the more outrageous things I suggest
because I look back now what was I
thinking I would read that book and
hardly
[Music]
you
[Music]